so potassium mint metal is very reactive
one of my colleagues used to work with
it described it as evil so we've come
out behind the chemistry department in
you a player to try and do a retake of
the potassium video the last sample of
potassium is very very small maybe 500
milligrams it will react so reactive
that if you have it in a box with argon
so that it can't get oxygen from
anywhere it will take the oxygen out of
paper which is paper as a compound of
carbon hydrogen oxygen and you can
extract this it's a reactive element
it's used in our body all the time we
have like lots of potassium floating
around been am we've got some samples in
about a gram maybe gram and a half of
each it's a pretty big chunk of
potassium this really yeah
Oh
very satisfying reaction after
completing 100 meters - like sodium it's
quite a low melting point metal and if
you mix sodium with and potassium
together to make so-called sodium
potassium amalgam it's called nak by
those who work in the trade na for
sodium k for potassium nak is a liquid
at room temperature looks a bit like
mercury a silvery liquid it's very light
and I never played with it
but people say that if you try and drop
it on the floor it will burst into
flames before it hits the floor because
it reacts with the water in the air
today I'm going to show you how to make
our potassium mirror we'll just fish out
a nice little bit of potassium it's
stored under mineral oil because it
reacts with water over time so it's
quite malleable stuff it's a little bit
like if you imagine cutting blu-tack
that's quite soft
and start to see it started to go off a
little bit already it's tarnishing a wee
bit so you can just manipulate it like
that and then we're going to pop it into
our ampule I'm going to evacuate it now
I'm going to remove all of the
atmosphere from this ampule okay we've
done that because the the boiling point
of potassium under one atmosphere is a
over 700 degrees C which is pretty high
it's too high for the glass to tolerate
if I heated it up to that temperature
the glass would start to soften and melt
so by evacuating it we remove all of the
atmosphere which is keeping that boiling
point as high as it is so it lowers the
boiling point much slower to start to
drop into the range of that of water
okay so just go into the blue flame
which is the nice hot flame we just keep
on gently warming it and at some point
it will melt just enough that you'll
start to see bubbles of potassium just
jumping out of this thin oxide layer
which is coating it at the minute and as
the movers starting to form so the
reason we do it like this is that we end
up with a large surface area of
potassium so it's excellent for keeping
our solvents dry so what we've got now
is we've got the ampule and all the way
up here this is literally a mirror of
very thin potassium potassium is very
important our bodies contain quite a lot
of potassium and it's in all sorts of
biological material if you burn garden
rubbish in the ash that you get in the
end is potassium which is presumably why
it's called potash so as Neal quite
literally wets the wall to get rid of
all that unreacted potassium
Oh wicked one of my colleagues who used
to work with it described it as evil